foreign
post office is now officially open you
have your letters stepped right in thank
you thank you hey loser what gives I
sent my letter and all I got was a lousy
clip of coal what serves you right
devilish little tadpoles like yourself
don't get toys from clouds oh yeah and
how would he know what I'm up to unless
you ratted on me
oh I didn't have to
he knows
ho ho happy holidays it is the Most
Wonderful Time of the Year hi my name is
Maude Garrett and welcome to an all new
episode of RT Essentials where we break
down your favorite tropes and genres
from across the spectrum of film and
television into digestible bite-sized
listicles like stocking stuffers in
video form you're welcome this week we
are focusing on holiday movies but
here's the twist this isn't your
grandma's It's a Wonderful Life or Die
Hard or Lethal Weapon by the way your
grandma has a great taste in film this
week though we are focusing on the new
class of holiday Centric feature films
movies that can either be about the
season or just take place during it and
you don't have to believe in Santa to
make it onto the nice list this year no
no as the saying goes there's no wrong
way to celebrate the darkest days no one
says that
but sit back relax and break out the
eggnog you know I've still never tried
eggnog
I've got no inclination to do so
elf everybody's killing me I only got
London choo choo pulling doubles
quick thinking yesterday with that
special talents thing
I feel bad for the guy I just hope he
doesn't get wise well
he hasn't figured out he's a human by
now I don't think he ever will
yes I figured out as a human by now I
don't think he ever will
you'd think that snagging a role in elf
would have been difficult but for some
it just came down to the right place at
the right time on the final day of
shooting John Favreau Will Ferrell and a
cameraman drove around New York City
looking for locations and would
occasionally pop out of their car and
grab whomever happened to be standing
nearby if they wanted to be extras for
some quick Mula those scenes were then
clipped into the early elf Montage of
Buddy arriving in the Big Apple getting
his shoe shined and jumping into traffic
which means that there are probably
people who to this day do not even know
that they're in the movie Elf
I'm just gonna lie and tell my friends
and family that if you squint really
really hard you can see me in the
background Christmas
[Music]
uh not now uh can you please go back to
the uh to the pit I'll come visit you in
a little while okay
you had elves working here
boy you're you're hilarious my friend
he doesn't
get back to the story please the film
originally had a deal with Macy's to
shoot inside a Macy's store and even be
incorporated into the famous parade
Macy's firm stipulation though was
removing the scene in which Pharaoh's
character reveals the store Santa to be
a fake Favreau and Co ultimately decided
to keep the scene and used gimbals
instead
you stink I think you're gonna have a
good Christmas all right not like beef
and cheese
[Music]
elf mocked Will Ferrell's first leading
role and despite it being a holiday hit
He has expressed zero interest in
reprising it turning down a reported 26
million dollar Payday for donning
Buddy's suit again maybe it's from the
chronic headaches he got from eating so
much sugary food for multiple takes I
mean I kid you not the spaghetti and
maple syrup scene had to be re-shot
after feral threw up the first time but
don't be too sad you can always catch
the elf musical which opened on Broadway
in 2013. Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
Jesus oh no no we're not ready for you
yet sir will you please go back out wait
with the others Grace do me a favor
let's just take him he's ready you ready
right you ready okay come on
you know the setup got any questions
he's got no questions look at him let's
go come on let's read Christmas crime
movies are a sub-genre Market cornered
by writer director Shane black you've
got your Lethal Weapon The Long Kiss
Goodnight nice guys Last Action Hero and
even Iron Man 3 which yes is a Christmas
movie but the real underrated modern
classic here is Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
Black's 2005 comedy Noir about a petty
criminal played by Robert Downey Jr who
gets mistaken for an actor playing a
criminal and is whisked off for a screen
test in Los Angeles where he finds
himself embroiled in a city-wide
conspiracy that would give Raymond
Chandler a run for his money I hope you
don't judge Los Angeles basic solely on
your experience here tonight huh
watch
you kind of scared here Barry
really why don't you give the kid a
break do unto others and all that it's
Christmas you know who else knows who
did you tell I don't know anything I'm
not even from here honestly Robert
Downey Jr owes a lot to this entry into
the Christmas
since it's the film that eventually
piqued the interest of John Favreau when
he began to float around the idea for
Iron Man Downey of course repaid the
favor by Landing black the director's
chair for Iron Man 3. now whether or not
that was the best idea is a conversation
for another time
hell Perry's got to be somewhere to turn
right in front of us
[Music]
foreign
there's no one in the car Harry what
co-star Val Kilmer met Robert Downey Jr
at a Hollywood party and a week later
got the script for kiss kiss and was
soon cast as gay Perry the detective
hired to Mentor rdj's Harry Lockhart the
character is pretty widely acknowledged
as the first openly gay character in a
Hollywood action film it was also Kilmer
who suggested the title from the less
elegant toss-up between lapi and bang
when asked why he likes to send to his
movies around the holidays during an
Entertainment Weekly interview he
responded Christmas represents a little
stutter in the march of days ahush in
which we have a chance to assess and
retrospect our lives so poignant also he
really liked the Sydney Pollock film
three days of the Condor and that took
place during Christmas so makes sense
claws
oh
when Despicable Me co-creator Sergio
Pablos wanted to tell a non-traditional
origin story in Klaus he went old school
not just in the source material which is
based not on the Jolly North Pole
resident we all know and love though
having JK Simmons voice 19th century
toymaker Saint Nicholas of Myra was an
awesome way to distinguish that this
Santa is not messing around he also
wanted the 2019 Netflix original to have
the look of an old-school holiday
classic the Spanish filmmaker opted for
a hand-drawn two-dimensional animation
style before adding digitally enhanced
volumetric lighting and texturing to
give claws some three-dimensional depth
if you're getting Iron Giant vibes from
this You are not alone that's my name
yes yay it's your name wow can you teach
me more please me next I want to write
my name is
the design used for the character of
claws was also not from traditional law
instead relying on descriptions used in
original folk tales of Saint Nicholas
opposed to the red robes look
popularized in Western media over the
years which yes we actually have
Coca-Cola to thank for that
Santa
so while the movie may look at first
glance to be recognizably old school
like Frosty the Snowman or Christmas
Comes to pacland which yes I checked is
a real Christmas special about Santa and
Pac-Man
oh bless that era
yeah oh close is actually a 2019 Netflix
original the first animated movie from
the streaming service to ever be
nominated for an Academy Award and
though the academy might have a hard
time Imagining the recent Whiplash
winner as Klaus JK Simmons was actually
able to draw on Real World Experience
having had a stint as a mall Santa
shortly out of college to pay the bills
during his early acting career which
means that even at 21 Simmons was being
Typecast as an old man Bad Santa
what do you want
well come on what do you want a snot rag
right another [ __ ] Marcus get this
kid off me before he pisses on me all
right Billy Bob Thornton and Bernie
macstar are in the hilariously raunchy
Bad Santa a 2003 dark comedy that
predated the bad role model Trend in
movies like bad teacher Bad moms Bad
Grandpa and even their sequels Bad
Grandpa 2 and bad Moms Christmas which
unfortunately did not make the cut this
year
this is gonna be cool
I guess I'll do fine
so I'm gonna be crashing here maybe just
you and me like roommates you know
do you and Mrs Santa have kids
plays William T stuff
con man with a drink problem I mean it
means already screaming
people who once a year poses as a mall
Santa in order to Mark department stores
to rob for Christmas cash with his
partner in crime the Coen brothers were
originally approached to helm the film
they turned it down when they couldn't
write the scripts themselves I mean
they're more Hanukkah guys but did help
out writing punch-ups and revising the
script they may have also helped sway
the casting before Thornton was brought
in for the titular role Jack Nicholson
and Bill Murray expressed interest in
the part both had to turn it down due to
scheduling conflicts but Thornton who
appeared in the Cohen films the man who
wasn't there and Intolerable Cruelty had
some avails thanks in part to his recent
separation from Angelina Jolie remember
those days
if I say yes then I will feel old so I
don't remember it at all
unfair practices get me no no no this is
not a handicap thing I I have nothing
against you people
you people
did you hear that Marcus he said you
people you people who the hell is us
people wait no no I you don't under
what speaking of Thornton he proved his
commitment to method acting by getting
so wasted during production of the scene
where he was supposed to fall down the
escalator that he actually fell down the
escalator so he may not have realized
that he was in a movie at the time
jingle jangle Once Upon a Time lived the
greatest inventor that ever there was
geronicas Django
Merry Christmas indeed jungle for the
last 30 years do yourself a favor if you
haven't already seen Netflix's first
live-action musical jingle jangle a
Christmas Journey the one with an
All-Star if totally Bonkers cast and a
soundtrack by John Legend featuring a
hit single by Usher added to your
Christmas watch list
what are you waiting for when there's a
musical that came out last year in which
Ricky Martin plays a sentient singing
Matador doll named Diego Don Diego and
he's one of the bad guys
man not since that boat ride and Willy
Wonka has a kids movie made us go is
this maybe a little bit too weird
if I have that toy I'll be unstoppable
it's foolproof
you are proof that there are fools fools
fools fools fools fools jingle dangle
was inspired by Classic Family films
according to its director including Mary
Poppins Dr Doolittle and the
aforementioned Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory uncredited but equally
influential homages abound Jangles got
elements of short circuit batteries not
included Mr Magorium's Wonder Emporium
and with that Diego subplot I guess
Child's Play unfortunately though buddy
is not voiced by Brad duriffs wearing up
a storm in the world's thickest Jersey
accent I'm Australian trying to do an
accent
but hey there's always equal
possibilities
okay
okay whoever that is
you're in for it
Journey
[Music]
you asked for it okay Netflix knew it
had a hit on its hands when two of the
movie's songs the square root of
possible and the Usher cover of this day
began garnering Academy Buzz for best
original song another single make it
work was shortlisted along with the best
original score nod though in the end
none made the official cut still Talbot
and his wife released two tie-in books
in time for the holidays jingle jangle
the invention of Veronica's jungle and
the square root of possible a jingle
jangle story you ever say a word so many
times that it just begins to lose all of
its meaning jingle jangle and Veronica's
jangle of the jingle jangle variety
Arthur Christmas hold on Father Intel
get me Intel Santa's head seems to be
resting on some sort of try me button
sir it's the quack quack moo activity
Farm sir it features 12 separate animal
sounds and sings Old MacDonald Had a
Farm the moment your father lifts his
head there'll be 10 seconds of constant
movie Arthur Christmas is a 2011 sleeper
hit that gets overlooked probably due to
its similarities to Fred Claus which
arrived in theaters just a few years
earlier but guys these are totally
different films instead of focusing on
Santa's burnout brother Arthur Christmas
is about the current Santa's youngest
son voiced by James McAvoy see in this
world Santa is a hereditary title that
is passed down through genealogy like
the British Monarchy or the magic voice
that Paul atridi uses in Dune
don't do use
cash
see who's Santa now
when his dad's high-tech slay
malfunctions Arthur along with his
grandfather the former Saint Nick played
by Jim Broadbent must help deliver all
the toys across the globe in a single
night to prove that he can fill Santa's
Big Belt slippers
oh dear you're slipper
we have lots we've got to get you down
now singers will be stuck give me that
what are you doing it's Evie thereafter
she doesn't fit this world after she's a
relic the 3D computer animated film
marks the first collaboration between
Sony Pictures aardman Productions a
British Studio known for films like
Wallace and Gromit Sean the Sheep and
Chicken Run
cheese
the filmmakers decided to move away from
aardman's stop-motion animated look but
still made a point to make the style
quirky with Easter eggs to aardman's
previous Works visible throughout the
film now whether or not any of the kids
watching Arthur Christmas were able to
pick up on the subtle Flushed Away
references is another matter Tangerine
28 [ __ ] days
I did not cheat on you
everybody
hey I'm gonna call a cop
you want me to call a cop Sean Baker's
2015 debut feature Tangerine is not just
an unconventional Christmas pick it's
also a totally unique movie a
cutting-edge scrappy Indie that was
ahead of its time both in terms of
production and plot shot entirely with
an iPhone 5s with some specialized apps
and lens applied Tangerine focuses on a
trans sex worker played by Katana Kiki
Rodriguez who gets out of jail only to
find out her boyfriend pimp is cheating
on her and enlists her best friend to
help teach him a lesson hi are we
looking for a party oh my God Merry
Christmas
[Applause]
Tangerine counts as a Christmas film and
you can fight us on it not only does the
movie take place during Christmas but it
began principal photography on Christmas
Eve of 2013 and wrapped just under a
month later which if you know anything
about production that counts as its own
minor movie Miracle I had two dollars
two dollars you know what I spend that
on
what the bus and a donut
since him
it don't matter we're here now sit down
the donut shop that serves as a large
setting for the film would later close
down and reopen as part of actor Danny
Trejo's donut chain Trejo's coffee and
donuts which honors the spirit of the
Season by offering both Christmas and
Hanukkah themed treats as well as
horchata flavored donuts called frosties
in the shape of a snowman which no has
nothing to do with the movie Tangerine
but any chance I get to talk about
Donuts
I do not stop
Tokyo Godfathers
if you're not an anime fan chances are
you've never heard of 2003's Japanese
language cartoon Tokyo Godfathers
conceived and directed by the late great
Satoshi Khan this movie is all about the
spirit of Christmas miracles even as it
takes place in a country that does not
celebrate the holidays as a custom
Godfathers tells the story from the
point of view of three homeless
characters a drunk named Jin I love the
pun a sarcastic teenager named Miyuki
and an optimistic and big-hearted
ex-drag queen Hana the three workers
stand-ins for the three wise men as well
as Joseph and Mary as they witness and
benefit from several seemingly
miraculous acts of Fate One winter night
the film contains numerous visual Easter
eggs referring to the Christmas date 12
25. it can be seen on an alarm clock a
key ring the cab fare and more
[Music]
what's another
oh yes yes
[Music]
while some see the story as a direct
interpretation of the Nativity Story
there are also elements to suggest the
film takes inspiration from another
classic Christmas Story A Christmas
Carol with the three homeless characters
representing Christmas past present and
future interestingly Tokyo Godfathers
was also inspired in part by the 1948
American Western three Godfathers which
was very not a Christmas movie
foreign
Khan who made his name with surrealist
anime like JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
paprika and perfect blue made a
deliberate effort to break away from his
usual style of dreamlike Storytelling
for Tokyo Godfathers a more grounded
film that focused more on characters
than devices or atmosphere but since
it's con you can still expect some
Fantastical elements seeping through the
narrative with unconventional Framing
and non-linear timelines so if that
stuff is your jam which it very much
should be Tokyo Godfathers is a perfect
Christmas film to recommend to friends
who have claimed to seen it all Carol
you can afford any of my mail to Chicago
General post
I've paid rent through February I had a
little extra
money saved
for our trip
our trip Terry and now you're
oh I believe this is happening Carol
Todd haynes's 2015 oscar-nominated drama
about a young female photographer
falling for an older wealthy woman in
1950s New York is not your conventional
Christmas film but bear with me here it
absolutely is after all Rooney Mara and
Cate blanchett's characters meet at a
department store right before Christmas
and was based on a real interaction
author Patricia Highsmith had while
working in the toy section of
Bloomingdale's during the holiday weird
tidbit High Smith also wrote the novel
strangers on a train you know the one
that's about another chance encounter
between two strangers but with very
different results for decades Highsmith
denied having written the novel the
price of salt for 38 years and only
fessed up to it in 1990 when it was
republished under the name Carol by that
time it already had published a million
copies anyway I got my eye on this
redhead who owns a steakhouse outside of
Paramus I'm talking
Rita Hayworth redhead really you think
you got what it takes to handle already
in 2018
promoted the unique Yuletide classic by
releasing The 12 Days of Christmas at
Carol sing-along which included eight
Blanchette side i7 Santa hat six rolls
of film five Jolly O's four pink berets
three fur coats two brown gloves and an
olive atopa martini
thank you played It For You on piano at
your house now remember
thank you oh God don't I look if you
needed any more convincing that this was
a holiday film it's right there in the
title it's a Christmas carol which
incidentally is what Kate Blanchett
would go on to name her dog love her
Love Actually
so Billy welcome back to the airwaves
new Christmas single cover of Love is
All Around except we've changed the word
love
to Christmas
yes is that an important message to you
Bill not really Mike Christmas is a Time
for people with someone they love in
their lives you can't say modern holiday
classic Without Love Actually popping up
in the conversation starring every
living British actor in 2003 and at
least three Americans all centered
around the Yuletide
their stories intersect over the span of
Christmas leading to new romances
heartache and most memeable use of
cardboard Sharpie signs in the history
of Cinema and fun fact that was actually
Andrew Lincoln's handwriting on the say
it's Carolina's Place cards that he
shows Keira Knightley though props had
made a version Lincoln thought that his
handwriting looked better and audiences
agreed although they kind of forgot that
this movie had Rick Grimes mutually
professing his love to the lady from
Pirates of the Caribbeans but there you
go
looking for anything in particular sir
yes
um
that necklace though how much is it it's
270 pounds
um all right I'll have it
lovely
[Music]
would you like it
gift wrapped
yes
lovely if you're like me you love love
actually as it's the perfect mix of
sweet and acidic gentle without becoming
saccharine characters aren't always
acting likeable Hugh Grant is a Tony
Blair stand-in having an affair with a
story version of Monica Lewinsky or a
very unsnake-like Alan Rickman cheating
on Emma Thompson
fun fact Emma Thompson did get cheated
on in real life and used that moment to
create that performance but they're
still worthy of Love Actually besides
what's more relatable than falling in
love with your non-english speaking
Portuguese housekeeper from The Chateau
that you moved into after you caught
your wife sleeping with your brother
during your best friend's wedding
classic Christmas predicament Sam
foreign
of course I do
oh Jesus
yeah I've gotta run
Love Actually has actually been rebooted
internationally more times than the
office in India it's been remade as a
film called a tribute to love Japan has
it all began when I met you and there's
a Polish version letters to Saint
Nicholas that just sounds like a
completely different movie but okay so
that brings us to the end of our rundown
of modern holiday Classics I hope you
found at least one or two movies that
weren't previously on your radar or at
least deserve a re-watch with the
Christmas or Hanukkah or
non-denominational season in mind from
all of us here at Rotten Tomatoes We
wish you a merry happy or at least
bearable end of the year however you
celebrate make sure to stay tuned as
we're going to have more great pop
culture content coming your way
[Music]